you know I've heard my entire life that
oh you're too nice of a guy for this
you're too nice a guy to play football
you're too nice of a guy for urban
politics so and so forth I think the big
challenge in life is 29 own self be true
to be authentically yourself and have
the courage to unleash that on the world
and and be as intensely you as possible
and not live by fear but leave by love
let your courage I'll be almost reckless
in your willingness to be who you are
and Barack Obama I applaud him for not
standing in the world and trying to
conform to it but being authentically
who he is and showing himself and saying
vote for me as I am NOT how ice my
pundits tell me to be in order to beat
him I'm Hillary Clinton's gonna be
myself so I reject that I laugh because
I watched a lot of things I see Obama
going through I've gone through my own
life first they say he's not black
enough well black people are going to
vote for him then they're saying always
too black and I mean just the the
nonsense that we project the pundits and
politicians often project on people that
are in the forefront is just frustrating
we have two phenomenal candidates
Hillary Clinton Barack Obama the party
is blessed to be in this crisis really
is many ways I remember sometimes
presidential primaries where you might
not have been as excited about the
various candidates that were in the race
this is a wonderful thing there are two
great candidates I may not know the
strategic machinations of the of the
pollsters and the like and what they're
worried about their concerns i can
actually imagine what they are but the
process is going to play itself out
there will be one candidate i hope that
it's been chosen fairly and i believe
that it will be right now i have no
reason to believe otherwise and it's
going to be another spirited
presidential debate in many ways between
two excellent candidates mccain and
somebody else and i hope that this
becomes a big election and now small
small election is that the whole
conversations about swift boat veterans
and they voted for something before they
voted against it and all that kind of
that kind of dialogue that's that that
does not serve our country but if it's
about our big bigger ideals and our
bigger values as Americans
the big visions of these individuals
have and we're choosing between the hope
the optimist and the plans and the
pragmatism of a candidate versus another
one that's going to rise our country up
to another level as opposed to but I'm
often as i express my frustration
earlier about often where we get we
dissent or Louis commonality